et cette maison devant laquelle nous ne
trouvons avec ses murs de tuf blanc
éclairé par un pare soleil d'automne ces
lignes classiques ces grandes portes
fenêtres c'est venu de bois et son 3 de
belles ardoises je vous étonnerai
peut-être en vous disant que c'est une
ferme
enfin d'habitation d'infirmier si la
ferme desbruères près de verviers en
plein saumurois et c'est l'infirmière
qui nous accueille
madame catala qui nous avons demandé de
nous faire visiter sa maison qui est à
peine achevée d'ailleurs je crois
elle comporte combien de pièces cinq
pièces oui tranchant à coucher la salle
de séjour dans laquelle nous sommes
magueye sow se compose de deux pièces
c'est cela et puis bien entendu within
sales blancs dans is we et la cuisine
mais quand vous êtes arrivé la cuisine
et est aménagé c'est à dire les
sanitaires seulement le potager oui dans
le fils ce que nous voyons là qu'est ce
que c'est bien c'est une entrée pour ne
pas avoir à se débarrasser dans la
cuisine ce soit alors monsieur était là
en rentrant du travail peut enlever ces
votes se parle à mon pote on peut
arriver du jardin potager avec ses
légumes et rincer sous le robinet sans
avoir à salir le potager qui est assez
délicat puisqu'il est tout blanc ce cela
et la cuisinière électrique
oui leur salle de bain et est également
aménagé
oui avec une baignoire lavabo le
chauffage qu'est ce que c'est comme
chauffeur et un chauffage à air pulsé
witi envoie de l'air par des gaines dans
toutes les places toutes les pièces
l'hiver évidemment ne passe encore mais
pas encore commencé mais nous ne l'avons
alinéa ouvriers est ce que cette maison
confortable mais elle est très
confortable d'abord il est de plain pied
ce qui est important pour l'entretien
toute la façade
oui quatre portes fenêtres de plain pied
oui et elle et vous m'avez dit qu'elle
était chaud de l'hiver et fraîche l'été
oui parce qu'on peut facilement la lyre
et nous sommes arrivés ici un saint ou
par une chaleur extraordinaire que
algérienne je ne supportais pas oui en
effet au total si vous avez ici je crois
on peut dire à peu près les avantages
d'une maison de la ville
en tout les avantages habité saumur
j'habitais paris
jnl davantage et c'est un bel exemple de
ce que l'on appelle le problème de la
rénovation de l'habitat rural mais parce
qu'on ne se sent pas déshériter voyez
vous oui et c'est un exemple qui devrait
je pense être suivie qui fera envie à
tout a beaucoup de fermières mais toutes
les fermières environnants sont venus
voir et tout longtemps apprécié vous
m'avez dit aussi quelque chose qui est
important c'est intéressant et important
pour la fermière mais aussi pour le
fermier en très importants comme un
homme arrive du travail qui ne sait pas
où aller dans sa maison pour faire ses
comptes pour retirer ses vêtements faire
sa toilette lire son journal
il me semble que ça démoralise
l'ambiance de la maison est très
importante pour un homme qui travaille
de même que le tracteur est devenue le
symbole de la modernisation du travail
de la terre la maison coquette
confortable équipé des derniers
perfectionnements devient elle aussi le
symbole du foyer campagnard capable
d'apporter le vrai délassement
après la dure journée passée dans les
champs